more than half of the residents in a
henderson nursing home contracted coping
19
according to the state's covet 19
dashboard now out of the reported 104
residents with the virus
29 died it's a story the i-team has been
following about
outbreaks inside of nursing homes and
now the granddaughter of a woman who
passed away says she wants answers
after her family was kept in the dark
the i-team's vanessa murphy is in studio
tonight with what she learned about this
case vanessa
denise yesterday would have been maxine
williams 90th
birthday her granddaughter says she
understands there was a pandemic and
people are going to catch covid19 but
she has questions about how the nursing
home where her grandmother lived
handled the situation
my grandmother died alone in the
hospital
maxine williams died of covid19
according to her death certificate
erin jones says her 89 year old
grandmother had dementia and was a
resident
at del mar gardens in henderson on july
17
her family received a call that williams
was taken to a hospital by ambulance
no one at the facility knew anything
they didn't know what hospital she went
to all they could tell us
she went by ambulance to a hospital
after several calls
jones says she was able to confirm her
grandmother was taken to saint rose
dominican hospital's
siena campus where she died they sent
her to the hospital
on a friday afternoon and she passed
away in the emergency room a couple
hours later she didn't make it to be
admitted
jones has questions about the days
leading up to her grandmother's death
the i-team examined 130 pages of medical
records that her family says they
obtained from del mar gardens
on july 8 williams had a cough and was
prescribed medicine
on july 13 she was tested for covid 19.
the cough was on and off through the
15th on the 16th
test results came back positive for the
virus
by then williams had a low-grade fever
she was given a nasal cannula for help
breathing
and records show she was so
uncomfortable she was moaning
on the 17th her oxygen level dropped to
75
medical staff noted that 90 to 100 is
normal
that's when an ambulance was called
how did they get that bad according to
these records staff reached out to the
family
six times over the course of the nine
days to provide updates
but the family disputes that jones also
says the family was
not allowed to communicate with williams
by phone or
face time as requested there was
something going on they were telling us
about
the attending physician identified in
medical records is dr
charles mcswain it is unclear from those
records whether he examined williams in
person before she was taken to the
hospital
when reached by phone dr mcswain told
the i-team
during that time he was not making
regular visits
and declined to comment further the
i-team also obtained state inspection
records for del mar gardens
the month williams died of the virus
there was one violation with at least
six different components according to
the department of health and human
services
this report dated july first states the
facility did not have sufficient
infection prevention and control
it is noted one resident who was being
monitored due to a fever and cough
was in a room with a resident who had no
covet 19 symptoms
their beds two feet apart the report
also noted
disinfectant cleaner not being used
properly
and laundry staff not wearing proper
personal protective equipment or ppe
in hindsight it kind of felt like she
didn't really have a chance to not get
infected
by august 13th del mar gardens provided
retraining and made changes to address
the deficiencies according to this
document
no deficiencies were found in two
additional visits
as of february 19th the state reports
58 percent of residents contracted covid
19
29 of them died i just want someone to
be held responsible
i reached out to del mar gardens i
called the nursing home three times
since december and i also reached out to
the corporate office three times
my calls were not returned and no
statement was provided
we'll continue to follow this story and
bring you any updates
vanessa thank you for that report
medicaid in